you're 22 pistol you might have the
right to keep and bear it but that
doesn't mean you have the right to make
it doesn't mean the other right to talk
to other people about making this is
Cody Wilson the crypto anarchist best
known for developing the Liberator a 3d
printable gun that was downloaded a
hundred thousand times in two days now
he's got a Bitcoin project called dark
wallet
Cody's all about DIY weaponry and
untraceable money if you're Chuck
Schumer he's the devil incarnate if
you're a libertarian well he's just
another Baudrillard quoting badass but
to everyone else Cody Wilson is an
enigma wrapped inside the barrel of a 3d
printed semi-automatic ar-15s and TV
we'll try to get to the bottom of the
Enigma if not the barrel over the next
half hour join us
hi I'm Todd crane in here for a reason
TV and I am here with Cody Wilson and
it's great to have you here
pleasure beer show Cody you've been
described as a troll as a genius as a
provocateur as a champion of the Second
Amendment and as one of the 15 deadliest
people on the face of the earth by Wired
magazine
I'm curious before you started this
business of 3d printing guns were you
prepared for the intensity of the
media's reaction to you and your work I
expected when we started what we did
that everything that could be said would
be said about us from you know
sociopathic dangerous you know homicidal
maniacs look I expected a level of
hyperbole I did and I thought that there
was a certain okay conceptual Rubicon
that I had passed and after that point
that I had kind of I would have given
myself over to being characterized and
basically unemployable and permanently
the kind of clown of digital
libertarianism for the rest of my life
it was quite a risk to take
we made the decision in full abandon
right in the kind of missile place where
we're like look is it even possible to
do this I don't know but we went on the
record trying to do it so like you're
probably going to be a failure and
regarded as like a charlatan and a freak
and some kind of idiot forever but we
thought well there's just enough of a
chance that it is possible and worth
doing and that it could really be some
game-changing level stuff that I went
for it and that's the thing like for
many many months I had the risk well
being permanently labeled it's like
ridiculous person and I'm probably
always going to be that you know but
like to the important people like to our
audience and to other people who are
listening we signal something very
meaningful and it took about a year to
get there and it's a year of humility
and it's a year of being made the most
awful person and a monster and you play
into it because it they carry your water
but like yes on the inside you're like
this is this is crazy and it's a very
very hard thing to do
did I see it coming yes I didn't know to
this it would come to this degree the
degree that it has and I'm lucky and
unfortunate in the fact that I put a
team together and we ended up doing some
of the things we needed to do so I have
legitimacy to do more things but it was
extremely risky on like a very personal
level
and what is the current state of defense
distributed are you still in the
business of printing printing designs
for 3d guns defense distributed is still
very much interested in being a digital
arms publisher a publisher for the files
for digital armament and where we've got
Allen guru we've got a nice legal team
you know like really interested in
having that fight insofar as it can be
had in this legal field to be that that
company again but for the moment this
company can't publish files in the clear
into the clear net without being
subjected to the most awful government
you know coercion so we've done other
things I opened up a second front and
Bitcoin I'm studying release of this
dark wallet software into the internet
and then we're looking at doing some
more prototyping and kind of talking
about it showing it even if we can't
release the files okay I'd love to get
into the whole dark wallet concept and
we'll get to that eventually
um but I was curious I thought you were
actually stopped from yeah from
circulating gonzo
yeah the United States State Department
has actually kind of asserted
intellectual property control over the
kinds of data I've generated and
specifically they claim that they are
the final authority or the only
authority on publication of that data
into the public domain so in the central
part of my project which was the
publication component has been for the
moment squelch for a year now completely
squats for that explanation I can
continue to develop files and maybe you
can put those up online in a way you can
see them but I can't let you download
them on the internet right now what tell
me a little bit about the conditions
under which they work well let's do it
man well it's a lot of people consider
the fact that because they can go buy an
ar-15 or Walmart that this is some
material confirmation that they have the
right to keep in their arms well in fact
there's a cold war legal regime that's
been constructed while everyone was kind
of asleep and waving flag basically the
United States State Department through
its political military Bureau of Affairs
asserts monopoly privilege over all
privately and publicly generated
technical data related to guns even
related to the maintenance of guns from
class one munitions up all through all
the military stuff so you're 22 pistol
you might have the right to keep and
bear it in some material sense but that
does
you have the right to make it that
doesn't mean the right you have the
right to talk about making it doesn't
mean you have the right to talk to other
people about making it
you see they start controlling every one
of these levels and at any liberal Court
will say well I'm seeing keeping barrier
sir in the text of the Second Amendment
prove to me you have the right to talk
about or make this weapon this is that
the task opposed to us that actually
sounds more like a First Amendment issue
right if it's about talking about it
funny how that works in the end that's
right yeah defense distributed has and I
think especially in the future will it
kind of merge these issues first and
second amendment now seemed almost
inextricably related at a certain kind
of level of fundamental level of
publication now some technology
companies like lavabit of which I'm sure
you know have chosen to actually shut
down in the face of more government
restrictions and regulations but you've
actually done the opposite in some way
you've gone you went a great deal to
comply with a lot of the rules oh so for
example the the undetectable firearms
act you actually modified your gun
design to make it comply with that and
you actually went as far as going for a
license to manufacture guns and I'm I'm
curious why did you given your branding
as an anarchist why go in that direction
the legal labyrinth that we were trying
to navigate actually ends up ending at
some unfinished rooms in 922 in Title 18
related to the farm manufacturing
there's an undetectable firearms act but
it actually has no guiding regulations
in the CFR it was just one of these fake
laws passed in the 80s and because the
nature of laws is kind of general roof
of security we thought that if we were
to just prototype these guns without
some type of a nominal licensing or some
type of nominal check that um it would
just give the excuse to DOJ or ATF to
kind of bust in the door to accuse us of
something the moment this all hit the
media of course I was right my intuition
the moment hit the media they did
something so we didn't want to give them
something that was maybe more
immediately available
ATF powers to come in and tell us we've
made illegal weapons the thing that we
did then even though there is a way that
I think you can make liber8 or pistols
title one you don't need a license might
try to show other people how to do that
to give us maximal coverage the most the
best first best ten potential
putting these into the internet I got a
license and then uh I took the most
conservative approach to manufacturing
quote undetectable weapons which was to
just have a detectable piece of metal
and all of our prototype frame I've read
though that the the piece of metal is
easily removed is that is that true oh
sure I mean any liberal is like but you
can take the piece of metal out well I
mean yeah but we epoxy it in there
because the law is like it needs to be
an integral part so I mean we box it up
and but of course you can take the metal
out it's funny to me that like some
liberals are like hyper lucid in certain
moments so like oh my god the metal is
removable you know well you know so is a
magazine from from you know like the
they're selective wood you get the sense
that they don't actually know much about
guns when they ask what no one cares I
mean no one knows no one cares Think
Progress and everyone banded on this
Chuck Schumer moment where there was
like oh my god it's a loophole a certain
gun components it can't be made of metal
what you know like we need to make gun
components essentially metal and freeze
the technology and you know they have no
business even being in the situation
it's so ridiculous like a whole class of
people can now determine like what
represents essential or necessary
technology or some kind of essential
platonic form of technology which needs
to be like the continued plateau of this
of this development know instead because
of the generalized paradigm of security
we have to freeze gun technology where
it is so they can match the kind of
security norms that we have and but and
you're all about showing how that's
actually impossible in the real so of
course yeah and not just showing it but
kind of like you know making that world
and forcing that crisis you say you've
been surveilled by the federal
government and I'm wondering hey how do
you know that and be what is that like
well someone we know we've been
surveilling in very obvious ways that we
could because we've invited the state
into our lives and and different
components right I have to have the ATF
FBI people come in and and do interviews
of I'm a dun and bradstreet registered
manufacturer one of our subsidiaries I
mean an exporter we have to do
interviews for that I mean the
government has it's this it's this
process where you invite it all into
your life and you subject yourself to
these investigations
you know fingerprinting all this kind of
stuff and then yes slowly we working it
was confirmed to us that we were being
monitored by Department Homeland
Security this was back in February of
2013 now can I can I prove that to you
right now I can say something that would
probably
fancy let's hear what up I said it a few
times in the median I don't you know I
don't - out our guy but we had a guy who
was former military get had some
connections higher up so you know I
don't really would give this guy away
but it was obvious to us through through
my connection third hand he was saying
he was only helping my engineer John he
had never even met me but one of his
superiors called him up and like what's
this I hear about you being in a
firearms investigation right they had
mapped my network they had mapped the
guys helping John and this guy got the
tip-off and told John yeah by the way
the Senate had approved an investigation
of defense distributed in its activities
I believe that there's no way I can
prove that that's true but I believe it
little material things though there was
an undercover cop outside my house for
like two months back right before the
liberator days and of course like when
we would check our server logs you know
DHS and DOJ would just sit on our
servers almost all day it was weird
reading these server logs all the time
so we knew for quite a while for many
months that we were the an interesting
object of study many different
government organizations that doesn't
stop what you're doing but it conditions
it to degrees so we were quite worried
with the development of Liberator that
there would might just be some assertion
of sovereignty like there might be a
National Security Letter right after we
develop a prototype or something telling
us hey don't don't put this in the
public domain so it actually kind of it
changed our thinking in the very end
change how we prototype and prototype
very quickly never Irish first the very
first one we had working we immediately
put into the public domain to prevent
the kind of assertion of control but it
wasn't enough to just fingerprint you
and subject you to you know periodic
searches actual when making guns in this
country you know serious business liked
about them and of course they would
rather you not do it that's part of the
aesthetic nature of this like the
baptize yourself into these processes is
to slow you down is to make you do less
and of course don't make more than 50
guns because then you pay a higher tax
and don't make more than 500,000 a
revenue because then you pay a much
higher tax my lawyers tell me things all
the time like well look when you go out
there show some contrition because it
doesn't like no but who knows how many
different federal agencies are looking
at you and your disposition and you know
be good you know I mean this is like the
coaching that I get from the people that
like I pay them to tell me to stop doing
what I'm doing
you know what I mean like that's
extremely frustrating can we talk a
little bit about the Liberator and what
is it what motivated you design it and
what's going on with it today the
liberator is the fulfillment of what we
called the wiki weapon project in the
beginning when I went to the Internet's
ask for people's money I was saying I
think we could 3d print a gun if we
could do that we would we would polish
the files for this gun and then anyone
could 3d print the gun and it wasn't
just a raw technical achievement I like
couched it in all this political
rhetoric about look it's a signal you
know of the of the future we imagine a
kind of counter template for what
distributed manufacture means it means
everyone would have access to the means
of production everyone would be able to
print guns it's a kind of like
antithetical critique not just a
critique but collapse of this
progressive idea about guns would be
kind of like channel to us through
legacy manufacturers and the FFL system
checked by the NRA and institutional
mediation gun production does didn't
mean institutional mediation all would
have access for none would you know the
revolution was was real everyone would
have access to guns so we packaged it in
a very symbolic package The Liberator
was it takes his namesake from a
psychological operation the old CIA the
OSS developed for world war 2 this was
the Liberator pistol drop that was
supposed to happen over occupied Europe
civilian resistance we're going to get
access to single-shot pistols and this
was supposed to like somehow unnerve the
occupying forces to some degree Oh
anyone might have a gun you know you
kind of baptize the whole like a
civilian population into this suspicion
you know Oh anyone could express their
latent criminality or will to resist
they didn't do it in the end the Allies
didn't do them because they didn't have
the nerve I really think that's the
reason it would make pacification on
there and that much more important
because let's face it we're dealing with
someone who'd have to occupy after the
occupiers so I took a page from baju and
baju says to create historical events
often there is an element of repetition
you rehabilitate some failed previous
historical moment and you kind of bring
it to its completion there's some
uniqueness and its historical poetry
when you can have moments like this so I
took the Liberator moment and I said we
can do liberator the digital allows for
a more effective Liberator job if the 3d
printed pistol is something that's
achievable we let's drop it into the
internet just like Liberator but this
time it was this pair of physical kind
of science-fiction nightmare with
logic of the West's of the great western
planners was returning to attack them
you know instead of the the Axis powers
the United States was we dropped the
Liberator on the United States and the
other Western powers you know the gun
control regimes
I did it I spy some these uh these these
frames of a World War two bombers in the
video you know and it was effectively
dropped and I considered it a kind of an
over bidding a kind of endless challenge
to these states to make their security
states real and of course they can you
said and I'll just quote you to you you
said the defense distributed is quote
really about anarchism the transcendence
of state and that that's what it's
really all about and I'm curious what
you mean by that about the whole concept
of flipping the power dynamic between
the oppressed and the oppressor what
explain that what's at stake with
something like The Liberator is that is
the knowledge and data related to the
manufacture of a firearm even at its
most crude and inefficient right but
it's very important for these nation
states these monopolistic legacy powers
to not let common people have access to
that information because therein lies a
certain shift in the equation of the
power dynamic 3d printers are still
mostly first-world middle class plus
technology they're kind of everywhere
around the world and so you'll see
Liberator videos from all over the world
Brazil Israel
you know Ukraine Finland people all the
world that printed them out and this was
confirmation that this model as possible
the platform was already diverse or
diffuse enough that okay what we said is
true this is now a global technology
people can print the guns and it's a
template of thought it's a template of
action this is how it's always going to
be as the printers become more
complicated as digital manufacturing
becomes more complex if you release some
of these guns or gun like implements
into the internet they'll be printed
anywhere all the time so it was at least
very strongly suggestive and I think it
was its most potent not in the actual
the real the physical Syrian resistance
fighters are going to be printing out
Liberator pistols unfortunately but at
the moment it's a kind of signal the
subjective nature of the genesis of
power itself that there is nothing to
get an intermediate between you and the
relationship you have with your computer
your networked printing device and that
this is extremely terrifying in its own
right and its own worthy level of
symbolic violence that outstrips any
real violence you could do with it
anyway the whole program in a sense is
designed to what you call force a crisis
in a sense oh yeah that also but that
ultimately liberate speak reate s'more
freedom right I mean that's that's in a
nutshell is that an accurate way of
talking about it
yes I'm often kind of accused of a
certain like naivete for thinking like
well what you're doing you think somehow
leads to freedom and don't you think in
the end you're actually the ultimate
kind of excuse for the greater
constrictions of freedom I think it's
already playing out and in fact I think
the legislative outcomes would have been
worse if I hadn't been me actually he if
it had been somebody else but I don't
believe that what we're doing leads to
changing the facts on the ground to like
a more free situation a more objectively
free situation anytime soon I believe
that these powers especially as their
survival like these nation-states like
when Bitcoin begins to kind of SAP all
the great the great powers they don't
just kind of wither away and the
situation doesn't get immediately better
for no reason they cling on to every
last bit of power the the legal kind of
modus operandi is the confinement of the
outside the legal regime says that
immediately that there is nothing
outside of it and so I mean you you give
it a kind of complex new like a dynamic
new network structure and it says well
there's nothing outside of me and then
it reaches to try to contain this to try
to contain Bitcoin to contain 3d printed
guns and yet we all understand in a very
functional practical way there's no way
that this confinement can successfully
happen this legal encapsulations no it's
not effectively possible so it's fun to
kind of challenge the state to greater
and greater levels of its own hyper
statism right challenge it in its own
kind of a regulatory bureaucratic
imagination and in baudrillard and these
other people that like really influence
ddu we say to challenge it successfully
enough leads to its own suicide its own
collapse from its own weight why is that
any system like on the verge of totality
it's also like simultaneously on the
verge of like immediate probable
subversion there can be no total
internet systems that can't also be the
system that delivers the Liberator to
the very you know goddamn heart of you
know everywhere I mean it's like it's
this fundamental reversibility of these
near-total systems there's a certain
kind of like logic to it
extreme logic a fatal strategy fatal
strategy Oh Joe calls it like fatal
theory understanding that like concepts
like antifragility and some of these new
network ways of thinking or like a
mimetic concepts like the Streisand
effect the greater the government or
authorities try to break down
information or censor it or or harbor it
or you know constrict it the greater its
potentiality to kind of spread
everywhere
I mean this is what the new network
effects are there are minds and like in
diaspora across like a spread across
these networks they're leading to
different and new kinds of strategies
for effectively evading not just like
sovereign observation but effective
means of state control and gatekeeping
the Internet has changed in things and
even if I'm accused of being like
Internet centric and utopian like the
Internet clearly makes available new
strategies Bitcoin being like the most
obvious and incredible and then you can
have these interesting phenomena like
releasing the 3d printer gun into the
internet or whatever so let's talk about
subversive strategies speaking of that
we'll talk about dark wallet
can you explain what it is it's an
in-browser extension Bitcoin in the
browser and that space is actually
heated up before right after we did our
fundraiser number of companies have
moved that direction dark well it's not
a company but we're going to be
releasing basically our first best
package of Bitcoin software that can do
stealth addresses for you can do a
version of money laundering called coin
join that we think can be done in a nice
way it'll handle the blockchain in a non
awkward fashion through a separate kind
of server set and it should in every way
just kind of um we think or should
embolden the digital libertarian to
carry out more of his affairs in Bitcoin
or let's say someone in the system D so
do more of their activity in Bitcoin and
not worry about you know being in the
regulatory tables of power and worrying
about you know having a bank account or
worrying about being investigated and
found out there's a number of startup
projects in Bitcoin that are not just
kind of carrying water or apologizing
for the legacy banking systems but are
like actively working with regulators to
tie software into their database
to triangulate identities and to create
white lists and green lists or to create
public blockchains what's so insane is a
lot of the people a lot of the first
year and second year people that were
connected to Bitcoin I'm using Jan very
loosely some of the first people on the
ground with Bitcoin technology we're
ostensively libertarian or at least you
know should have been and then this is
kind of this furious rush to the east
and west coast either to cozy up to the
financial powers in New York or to get
some VC money out on the west coast
they're just kind of like paper over the
cracks in the old institutional banking
system the old money system and to say
to tell this kind of story with Bitcoin
they're like oh well Bitcoin is what
we've been waiting for to kind of
perfect what had been at this point kind
of incomplete my advice to people this
Bitcoin conference yesterday was know
that system is very much in disrepair
and what is falling should be pushed you
know it's a Bitcoin represents the
question mark on this system let's go
all the way the other direction
don't apologize and make you know get
money to make up this system and to kind
of prop it up for a while
abolish this system go in a different
development direction the dark the dark
wallet black bloc anarchists are
pursuing an alternative development
direction which reifies a certain kind
of nightmare that the security state had
back in the crypto Wars that there is a
go dark problem that oh my god one day
all this activity that we monitor might
just somehow disappear from us it might
run from us how can we pursue it it so
in a way dark wallet is about having
Bitcoin and ultimately live up to its
promises and exactly it's about a you
know what's what's the kind of Bitcoin
we actually want as a digital
libertarian tool right now it's it's a
pure technology the self it has none of
it has none of the qualities it's kind
of purported to have I'm not criticizing
I'm just saying like it's worse than
cash you know it's in every transaction
is permanently kind of investigative or
most people don't use they don't reuse
addresses and stuff and so it's actually
kind of much more a technique of your
own surveillance and binding to external
power than then you might imagine it's
like and like these Bitcoin ATMs have
biometrics and stuff I mean it's this
kind of perverse way of talking about
the money of the future when really it's
just like the perfect money of your own
subjection and how's the new effort
being funded how's that going well we
raise like
we raise like six figures online and
crowdfunding we've gotta kind of get a
crowd funding over the over the year so
he raised a bunch of money on
crowdfunding and we've funded it for the
last few months doing well yeah it's
good I don't need any more money I think
we're good we'll have a release in April
I've timed it with a ABC Nightline piece
so it's already well hell of a wait I
guess any publicity is good publicity I
mean yes of course I agree but the
strategy goes a bit deeper I mean you
mentioned crisis forcing for me the
level of rhetoric has ratchet up to such
a successful degree in Bitcoin we have
Joe Manchin who it's not an accident
also wanted to ban on assault weapons in
manchin-toomey now saying we should ban
Bitcoin Chuck Schumer Dianne Feinstein
and Joe Manchin who are these people
what the hell is going on and why do all
these issues like this the muscular
defense of the welfare security warfare
state the banning of Bitcoin and assault
weapons all converging these people in
these very strange ways it's a
mystifying but now that there's this
level of rhetoric about banning Bitcoin
completely because Russian trying to
have them because I don't want Americans
to suffer risk it is perfect like
fertile bed to kind of throw in it's ABC
Nightline peace in primetime we're like
mom and pop and everybody money they're
my business kind of gets a taste of
Bitcoin as like you know the currency of
the apocalypse and oh my god what are
these digital laboratories doing and the
symbolic violence again it's something
like Liberator I want the very next day
Chuck Schumer be Outland okay this is
ridiculous but it appeals to a certain
contrarians shrieking oh man yeah well
everyone's in Bitcoin especially and the
Bitcoin people deserve this everyone is
trying to avoid the catastrophe and this
is the episode of the Bitcoin foundation
this is the the moral lesson that is
Charlie shrooms life at this point
everyone's trying to avoid the
catastrophe by what creating it oh well
we will in order to avoid the terrible
regulatory outcome we should go become
the regulatory interface at least at
least if we tell the congressional
people how to regulate it they'll
regulate it better than if somebody else
fill the vacuum fill the void well no
man the lesson from again Foucault Kafka
the 20th [ __ ] century is that you
can't participate in these processes and
not create that outcome that's the kind
of like stupid ironic outcome that
happens and so everybody every Bitcoin
er after San Jose has been
implement of the destruction of this
currency it's co-option and ultimately
like its grand regulatory you know
confined so you've got a big book deal
with simon and schuster
yeah yeah no I sold a proposal in in the
end of 2013
actually it's weird because there was
this very bimodal reception right it's
either like this guy's crazy this is
terrible or this guy's extremely
interesting shut up and take our money
you know what what's the book gonna be
about ah okay so like Catcher in the Rye
meets the digital apocalypse that sounds
great but I have no idea what it was so
I mean the excuse for telling the gun
was of course the Liberator pistol you
know defense distributed you know
incursions into the gun debate you know
and the historical grounding to of the
post Sandy Hook fight and then kind of
our travels and all the strange
communities that we met along the way
the communities of the no reaction in
San Francisco the dark enlightenment
guys the zeitgeist people the weird
singularity people the anarchists
hotbeds Europe the strange expats the
nation-state games going on the spies
being kind of funded encounter fun to
them all these people we kind of ran
through these different layers we're
always around us we had to like meet
when you do an extreme project you meet
extreme people so I mean this is an
excuse to investigate these peoples
frame of thought I want to criticize
David Brooks I want to bring up the post
Snowden moment I want to have a
generational divide between we the kind
of despairing Millennials we were so
much a political but also like capable
versus the baby boomers who are close to
achieving medical immortality and are
the greatest sinners who have lived on
the earth sounds dangerously close to a
manifesto to me I mean yeah but I want
to do it novelist iggly you know I don't
I don't know I just kind of write it out
it's boring hopefully it will it will be
a stepping stone toward young radicals
of radicalization maybe it'll be in the
library of certain digital libertarians
in the future I mean I want to explain
how we did what we did our intuitions
about the Society of the spectacle
certain things we learned about the
media certain ways you were able to play
the state and its institutions against
itself that were like we're real and
happened and we're
kind of almost outrageous and difficult
to believe but I'm much more interested
in the storytelling in a kind of
Baudrillard Ian you know postmodern
visual sentence you know where
everything takes on like historical
poetics and I mean it's extremely
pretentious but you're selling it very
well but if you package it just right
and the hope is what to inspire the next
generation of Cody Wilson mostly to tell
a really good story man
I hope it's worthy of the title of you
know literature in the end so Cody
Wilson it's a pleasure to have you I had
a lot of fun thank you for the question